this is so exciting
jamie here we are it's time for dear
drew one of my very favorite segments
i have to tell you there are things that
sometimes i can't believe we're getting
away with on the show
i was like we let's do dear drew and get
into snail mail and here we are
and more incredibly ember was a little
pessimistic wondering if people would
send mail
in and i'm just gonna say look at
one particular woman we're gonna get
into so
i mean snail mail is alive and well and
i know it's huge this week
and uh we're going to start we celebrate
a zip code every week and we're going to
start today
with the zip code of the day that's
right it's 1911
in philadelphia pennsylvania home of our
local affiliate cbs3 philadelphia
some fun facts about philly hmm first
the first hospital in the u.s was
founded in 1751 by dr
thomas bond and benjamin franklin
philadelphia is also one of the most
thriving art scenes
in the country pillow barns most
impressionistic paintings outside of
paris including van gogh's sunflowers
rocky made steps to philadelphia art
museum
very famous and uh last fun fact
it's a personal one my family is
actually from there yeah hundreds of
years they were doing theaters
there was the druze and the barrymores
they married into each other hence
through barrymore and they actually
permanently reside there here's some
photos of me
at their grave site that i went to with
my friend robin who lives right outside
of philly and
fun fact i broke into the cemetery
it was closed i hopped the wall and
robin's like so
into rules and she was not thrilled but
she went with it anyway
so philadelphia pennsylvania i would
love to hear
from you when you get over all of your
busy business please send me some mail
okay first let's get to our first letter
bev chapman all right
bev i love you from vista california
you have sent us like bev i mean oh my
god you know what let's just go for it
look bev
look at you look at you hundreds of
letters the past few months
and mostly with a cute joke which is
adorable because i
send my daughters jokes on postcards so
let's read a couple first
joke what's the coolest vegetable
a radish i know
the second joke it's hot i bought a loaf
of bread and by the time i got
home it was toast
okay bev i just i'm obsessed with you
please keep them coming
we'll keep it reading okay eva from
morgantown west virginia writes oh dear
eva is this eva's letter right here
oh no where did eva's letter go all
right we're live
this is fun we have fun i think this is
eva's letter
it is oh dear drew i work at a local
university
in the procurement department but my
love and my passion is art and i have
included a small painting i did a few
weeks back i hope you like it
oh eva you sent me a little painting
this is exactly the whole point of dear
drew okay we have time for one more
letter from mary in chesterton
uh indiana phew
by the way fun fact about it's like the
first and second initials or the first
and last it can really throw you okay
my question is for you what kind of
mattress do famous people sleep on
we spent two thousand dollars on a
mattress that we gave away less than a
year later
i didn't even have the conscience to
send to take any money
for such terrible quality replaced it
with an organic latex mattress
something about latex and mattress
sounds real odd they go together but not
you know in that way
and added to the plush topper than a
cotton topper yet i still feel like i'm
sleeping on a forest floor
okay mary here's the deal if you're
gonna go topper
tempur-pedic for sure because i have to
always travel for work and i've had to
live in
random cities and hotels for months at a
time and i never travel without my
tempur-pedic topic
topper it makes every mattress amazing
but
my personal preference is one from the
sealy brand and that's what i have at
home so i'm gonna send you both
and you're gonna get to test drive and
see which one you like better okay
now if anyone out there needs any advice
help
maybe wants to see me try something mail
me your questions requests photos
jokes no one can top bev at this point
but please try
funny stories family memories photos
i can't wait to read your letters on the
show so bev and eva and mary
thank you for your letters and here are
my postcards to you
stamped and everything good if there
isn't something i love more than stamps
i'd love you to find it
i know puppies thank you
truly yours love drew
[Music]
you